معنا من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوط هشام
جديد الوضع الميداني في غزه وقد شاهدنا
قبل قليل تصاعد اعمده الدخان في في القطاع
مع تواصل القصف الاسرائيلي لعده
مناطق بالفعل تتصاعد اعمده اعمده الدخان
من جراء استمرار القصف المدفعي والغارات
الاسرائيليه المتفرقه التي تشنها
المقاتلات الحربيه الاسرائيليه ما بين
فينه واخرى هناك غارات عنيفه على مناطق
مختلفه من قطاع غزه نبداها من منطقه شمال
القطاع حيث تشن الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه والمدفعيه كذلك على المناطق
الغربيه من بيت لاهيه غارات وقصف مدفعي
عنيف على تلك المناطق ايضا المناطق
الشرقيه ل جباليا ومنطقه بيت حنون ايضا
تتعرض ما بين فينه واخرى الى قصف من
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه لكن الغارات ربما
الاكثر عنفا والاكثر حده هي على مدينه غزه
مدينه غزه باتت تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من
الطائرات الحرب ربيه الاسرائيليه وكانها
تعود الى الايام الاولى للحرب الاسرائيليه
منذ بدات هذه الحرب واسرائيل تشن غارات
عنيفه وتتركز هذه الغارات على مدينه غزه
دمرت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه احياء
باكملها مسحتها عن الوجود وعن الواقع في
مدينه غزه احياء باكملها دمرت والمنازل
بكل تاكيد من جراء هذه الغارات
الاسرائيليه والغارات مستمره ومتواصله منذ
عده اسابيع ربما انخفضت حده هذه الغارات
لكن منذ امس ن على الاقل بدات الغارات
تكون اكثر عنفا واكثر حده في مدينه غزه
الغارات تستهدف احياء مختلفه حي الصبره
كان قبل قليل استهدفته الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه وكان هناك استهداف لمنزل
لعائله مدوخ وعائله اخرى في حي الصبره
ايضا حي الزيتون تعرض الى قصف عنيف من
الطائرات الحربيه ايضا الدبابات
الاسرائيليه تتمركز وتتركز في محيط مستشفى
ومجمع الشفاء الطبي المدمر اصلا والخارج
عن الخدمه وايضا المناطق الغربيه لمدينه
غزه حي الرمال الجنوبي ومنطقه ابو مازن
ومنطقه دوار الماليه وايضا مفترق الازهر
عند مدينه غزه في المناطق الغربيه ايضا
مفترق العائلات وحي النصر والشيخ رضوان كل
هذه المناطق الغربيه لمدينه غزه سواء كانت
الغربيه الجنوبيه او الشماليه تتمركز فيها
الدبابات الاسرائيليه وتقصد بعنف المنازل
المدنيه الفلسطينيه الجيش الاسرائيلي يفتش
من في داخل المنازل ويعتقل السكان ويجبر
بعض العائلات على النزوح الى مناطق وسط
وجنوب القطاع في المنطقه الوسطى ايضا اذا
انتقلنا اليها فالقصف مركز على المناطق
الشماليه لمخيم النصيرات ايضا قبل قليل
كان هناك عده استهدافات من قبل الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه عرف منها منزل في
مخيم واحد
في في مخيم النصيرات وايضا منزل اخر في
مخيم اثنين في مخيم النصيرات وحتى الان لم
يعرف بعد اذا كان هناك اصابات او شهداء من
جر هذه الغارات الاسرائيليه ايضا القصف
المدفعي مستمر في المناطق الشماليه لمخيم
النصيرات وهذه المناطق تتعرض منذ عده
اسابيع الى قصف عنيف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه لكن ايضا القصف ربما الاكثر
عنفا والاكثر حده هو في خانيونس خانيونس
لوحدها قصه ولوحدها تتعرض لقصف عنيف
الحصار الاسرائيلي مازال مستمر على مدينه
خانيونس الحصار الاسرائيلي مازال مستمر
على مستشفى ناصر في مدينه خانيونس وهذا
المجم الطبي الاهم الان في قطاع غزه بعد
خروج مجمع الشفاء الطبي عن الخدمه ايضا
مستشفى الامل مازال محاصرا وبالتاكيد مركز
الامل الذي كان فيه الاف من النازحين
الفلسطينيين الان مصيرهم مجهول في ظل هذا
الحصار واستمرار هذا الحصار الاسرائيلي
على حي الامل وبالتاكيد على مستشفى الامل
ومركز الامل الذي يحتوي على النازحين
مستشفى ناصر وهذا المجمع الكبير ما زال
ايضا محاصرا الاطباء يعانون والمرضى
والنازحين في هذا المستشفى يعانون من جراء
نقص المياه من جراء نقص الغذاء وبالتاكيد
الدواء فلا امدادات طبيه لديهم ولا
امدادات للغذاء ولا امدادات للدواء ووزاره
الصحه تتحدث عن ان الجيش الاسرائيلي ايضا
يستهدف مقومات الحياه في هذه المستشفى
وهذا المجمع الطبي وايضا حتى في المنازل
المدنيه الفلسطينيه المختلفه في مدينه
خانيونس خاصه في المناطق الغربيه الجيش
الاسرائيلي يستهدف خزانات الم في مستشفى
ناصر وبالتالي لا يوجد مياه في هذا
المستشفى لا يوجد غذاء الجيش الاسرائيلي
متمركز وما زال متمركزا على الطريق العام
الرئيسي في المناطق الغربيه لمدينه خان
يونس ويجبر الناس من المر على المرور من
امام الدبابات يعتقل الرجال ويترك النساء
الى للنزوح الى مدينه رفح بدون اي من
مقومات الحياه لا يسمح لهم لا باخذ غذاء
ولا باخذ الفراش ولا باخذ الاغطيه ولا
باخذ اليام وبالتالي يذهب الناس الى
المجهول هنا في مدينه رفح شكرا لك مراسل
الجزيره هشام زقو كنت معنا من رفح